in this video i'm going to show you how
to create a vintage b-movie title that
will make your friends think you're a
hollywood pro
hi there my name is cameron with motion
science this is the first video in a
series of videos where i'm going to
teach you how to create an eye-catching
attention-grabbing sci-fi b-movie title
with a little bit of creativity and some
simple tips you'll be able to come up
with a title that will make people
excited to see your film so let's get
started in this first part of this
series i'm going to create an asteroid
field
and you're welcome to follow along with
this lesson on cinema 4d
or you can find your own image from a
simple google search like i did here i
searched out asteroid alpha and all you
need here is just a simple
asteroid that you can take into
photoshop and cut out the alpha channel
and you'll be good to go we're going to
create our own asteroid though in this
example so what i have here is a sphere
and i've turned off render perfect i've
also selected
this option right here i've created 24
segments and i have a radius of 100.
next thing i'm going to do is apply a
texture
i have applied a noise filter and you
can see here i set the color one to
black the color to white
i changed the
noise to blister turbulence octaves to
five next i went into the bump channel
also added a noise texture which you can
see here how it's starting to look with
that noise channel again black and white
blistered turbulence octaves five and i
scaled down
globally to 20
and the last thing i did was i went into
my displacement map here
i turned it on
and
sub polygon displacement is not on by
default so it looks like this
but once i turn it on it looks a lot
more visually interesting like we see
here now what i did was i applied a
layer texture and within that layer i
have three layers of noise
and again you can see i used blister
turbulence
five octaves and i'll step back
go into my next
layer which is set to
this noise here
and global scale is turned up to 100 and
i'll step back again and my last layer
is also this texture global scale is set
to a 1000 and i played around with the
seed on a couple of these just to get
some different looks
i also reduced the opacity of these top
two layers here for 10 and 20 percent
and that's it the next thing i did was
added two directional lights which we
see here one is set to a light blue
color an intensity of 150 percent it's
an infinite light with shadow maps set
to soft this is my bottom light which
gives it a blue tint the next one is an
infinite light top light it is set to a
value of
white
intensity 120
infinite ray traced hard just to give it
a little bit different look
and the last that i turned on here is an
omni light and i'll go ahead and turn it
on it's set to a blue color as well and
the intensity is set down to about 30
which we can see here
no shadow maps
next i went to back to my sphere here
and i set a keyframe uh for the rotation
so i have a keyframe set for the h
rotation to zero and i set my timeline
to 240 frames went to the very last
frame and set it to 180 degrees
so that it rotates very slowly like we
see here last thing i did was go up into
my render settings
i set my output to be 500 pixels by 500
pixels the reason i did that is because
we're going to be using a particle
system and it does not recommend any
renders over 500 pixels set it to all
frames
saving it as a png sequence
16 bits per channel alpha channel and i
also turned on ambient occlusion which
we can find right here under effect
turned that on default settings
and then i clicked render to render an
image sequence and then i jumped into
after effects in after effects i'm going
to go ahead and import this image
sequence as a png sequence
click open
i'm going to right click interpret
footage main and set this to 24 frames
per second because that is how i
rendered out of cinema 4d and drag this
into a new composition which we see here
and we're going to set this to full and
i'm going to go ahead and preview this
and you see we have a really simple
animated rock rotation
that we are going to use for our
asteroid field we're going to drag our
pre comp into our composition just like
this we're going to go ahead and turn it
off and we're going to lock that layer
going to layer new solid
and we're going to call this
particles
and click ok and to this layer we are
going to apply
rg trapcode particular and once that's
loaded up we're going to move forward in
our timeline here so we can see some
particle systems and we're going to
change our emitter to a box
and we're going to
increase the size of our box here and
actually open up our emitter size here
and turn off xyz link make it xyz
individual
and we're going to make our x size
pretty wide probably around 2000 we're
also going to make our z
really big so it encompasses
our full composition
maybe something like that
and we're going to go down into our
environment and turn on some wind here
and let's just see how this looks okay
next thing we need to do is we need to
turn off our velocity so we're going to
turn it from 100 down to zero so that
those particles don't fly off everywhere
next we're going to do here is we are
going to set our particles per second to
something like 100 and then do page down
and turn this to zero the reason we're
doing this is because we don't want
particles to keep appearing
so something like this
now we need to extend the life of our
particles we're gonna open up our
particle system here and we're gonna go
to life per second and let's just turn
this up to something like 10
so if they just stay on there
[Music]
so that's looking pretty good i think we
need to increase the amount of particles
per second at the beginning here so
maybe something like
500.
yeah i like that a lot next thing we're
going to do is we're going to change our
particle type from sphere to sprite and
we're going to open up sprite controls
and we're going to select our layer
which is our rotating rock and go ahead
and let that load in here we're also
going to change this from random loop to
split clip
loop we'll try that one see how it looks
actually let's go ahead and increase the
size of our particles to something like
20 let's just see how those look
not too bad i want something that's
visually more interesting so i want to
go ahead and bring these the particle
system closer to the camera and let's
just try and increase the size of our
emitter z
to bring them closer to us here
something like that and let's also
decrease the size of emitter y so it's
more of a
narrow
field kind of going past us there yeah
that's looking pretty cool
i still think we might need a few more
that are closer to us the reason i used
an animated texture here is because we
can see
this asteroid
rotating as it's pushing back so it
gives us more visual interest like i
said you can use an image in here
and you're it's gonna still look great
it's just that this is a little bit more
visually interesting to look at i'm
going to increase the size a little bit
more maybe something like 30. i don't
want them to be too big that's too big
so maybe 25
and let's go ahead and see it's looking
pretty good
also let's go ahead and add some size
randomness so we're going to turn up our
randomness to 100 so they're all
different sizes
and let's go and turn on rotation
oriented motion let's go ahead and turn
that on
a lot of these settings are based on
just trial and error so i like to just
kind of come in here and play around
random rotation i'm also going to turn
that up to 100 so that they all are just
rotated slightly differently and this is
looking pretty good now i want to go
ahead and back this layer up here so i
can preview the entire composition and
that's looking pretty good as well
one thing i want to do here is i would
really love to start closer to this
asteroid so let's go ahead and add a new
camera
layer new camera we're going to keep it
one node we're going to turn off depth
of field for now 50 millimeters fine
click ok
and with this we're going to push in
closer to our asteroid field here
and i want to play around a little bit
more with the size of this maybe 5 000
maybe 3 000 let's make the emitter even
bigger let's go to 10 000. let's take
the y just a little bit bigger let's try
350. that's looking pretty good we can
also go ahead and turn on our depth of
field here
i'm gonna hit aa and turn on depth field
something like that
and maybe push this out a little bit and
that's on and that's off gives a little
bit more
depth to the piece and there we go it's
looking really nice as well
and let's go ahead and bring in these
nebula images these are just still
images or pngs with transparent
backgrounds that i played around with
photoshop and got them
to
have some alpha channels to them so i'm
going to go ahead and scale this one
down maybe about 50.
bring it over in here
pick the next one we'll scale down to
about
30.
bring it over in here and this last one
we're going to turn it on and hit scale
and bring it down pretty small
something maybe in here and to all three
of them we're going to select them and
go to effect blur and sharpen camera
lens blur and we're going to create a
blur of about
20. so all three now have a blur of
about 20 on them and solo them
and you can see it creates just some
more depth back there in the background
and to wrap this video up let's go ahead
and increase the size backup of the
asteroids to about 35.
and i'm going to preview this and that
is looking really cool
so that's going to do it for video
number one in the series i hope that
you've really enjoyed this lesson on
creating a sci-fi b-movie title please
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments i'd love to answer them for
you hit that like button if you enjoyed
this video and please subscribe to this
channel it helps other people find this
channel as well if you're looking to
upgrade your design skill set master the
art of style and execute like a pro i
have a course called stylecraft that you
can check out at motionscience.tv
you can also learn more about this
course by clicking the link in the
description as always thanks for
watching i'm cameron and this is motion
science
[Music]
you